well I think the important thing that
we've forgotten is what is the purpose
of the government we have constant water
main breaks the roads are in terrible
shape and then we're going to give money
so a bunch of corporate executives can
can watch a football game eight times a
year it's absurd
after 20 years of being a football
wasteland Los Angeles is one step closer
to bringing back the NFL the Inglewood
City Council voted 5-2 nothing to
approve this massive stadium project two
billion dollars 80,000 steet a seat NFL
stadium supporters say this will bring
10,000 jobs and tens of millions of
dollars in tax revenue the deal that's
been offered to the city this is
financial arrangement is the best
financial arrangement in the history of
stadium deals in this country developers
of the Inglewood project plan to finance
the new 1.8 billion dollar stadium
entirely with private funds a deal that
would be great for the city and an
oddity in the sports world for most
facilities require millions and public
dollars to be built but the Inglewood
deal hasn't stopped other localities
from aggressively pursuing new stadium
projects with public money if anything
the likelihood of a new facility in Los
Angeles has created a bidding war
between cities hoping to attract or keep
sports franchises in their part of town
take st. Louis the city is proposing to
fork out 400 million in tax dollars to
build a new billion dollar waterfront
stadium to keep the Rams from leaving
and with the threat of another team on
their home turf the Chargers and Raiders
want to turn this stinky old garbage
dump into a brand new 1.7 billion dollar
Stadium in Carson California while
details of the plan have yet to be
released it's been reported that the
financing would be similar to the 49ers
stadium in Santa Clara which was spread
at 621 million dollars in construction
loans paid for with public money even
the union-busting fiscal conservative
Scott Walker is not immune to the
stadium craze the Wisconsin governor
wants to allocate 220 million in public
bonds to keep the Bucks basketball
franchise in Milwaukee it is a free
market approach to say we're gonna help
the buck
stay here and pay their own way but
these teams often do not pay their own
way and instead use public money to
generate private revenue in the past 20
years the United States has opened 101
new sports facilities stadium finance
experts say that almost all of them have
received public funding totaling
billions of dollars and even though
study after study has shown
- no economic benefit why do cities
continue to be so stupid when it comes
to building stadiums this is a typical
case of cities really responding to
questions of image what corporate
sponsors want and of course the unions
are going to back it because they will
all be Union construction jobs and so
they'll get those two but does it really
serve the needs of the people does it
really serve the needs of these
neighborhoods particularly in places
like Englewood and Carson and LA which
have large populations of poor people
who you would think would rather have a
good job than the chance to say oh yeah
we live in the other stadium which of
course I can't afford the tickets anyway
the irony of most of these stadium
financing deals is that residents in
debt paying taxes to fund a facility
they can't afford to attend but many
people will still support the idea of a
stadium project because of the promise
of new jobs and increased revenue for
the neighborhood but are these rosy
economic projections valid most the
studies will show that they actually you
end up losing money
it's really a question of political
power and influence and basically
football teams of attract corporations
because the corporate executives get the
free boxes and so they like it having a
stadium you know I mean it may bring
some business and residual business but
you know most people when they go to a
sports event they eat at the stadium
they don't they don't hang out at the
restaurants in the downtown area and so
III just think that this is sort of a
you know sort of a fanciful approach
towards economic development instead of
building really good jobs and except for
the construction the jobs created by
stadia are generally low wage occasional
work I mean again occasional weizen 16
times a year it's been shown time and
time again that stadiums are poor public
investments and with so many cities
strapped for cash perhaps it's time that
taxpayers stop paying for them
click for more and subscribe for all the
latest reason TV videos